ce matin nous avons appris la mort d'un
créateur d'un peintre américain keith
haring terrassé à l'âge de 32 ans par la
maladie du sida cet artiste de renom et
de grand talent s'était distingué en
décorant entre autres un mur de
l'hôpital necker à paris une église à
pise et puis une paroi murale de la
maternité de monaco au mois d'août 89 ou
l'une de nos équipes précisément l'avait
rencontré ce jeune américain de 31 ans
doit se renommer aux murs de new york ou
plutôt aux graffitis qui via les c ils
se vendent aujourd'hui plus de cent
mille dollars
on parle de génie de sa génération pour
lui ça me dépasse un peu il plaît voilà
tout il est riche célèbre avec un coeur
gros gros comme une montagne si travaux
dans les hôpitaux les églises pour les
enfants il est fait bénévolement à
maintenir noir
pourquoi je peints sur les murs parce
que je peux dans un hôpital
j'aime pas dans plusieurs hôpitaux et
plusieurs couteaux m'ont demandé de
prendre quoi vous demandez pas d'argent
parce que lorsque je peins dans un
hôpital où les écoles c'est un kazan
pour rendre l'endroit plus agréable et
rendre les gens heureux et je ne peux
demander de l'argent pour les peintures
les sculptures l'image fétiche de kate
c'est ce bébé à quatre pattes qui
trimballe partout quoi de plus normal
que d'accoucher d'une oeuvre d'art dans
une maternité
salut kate